I would like to speak now to the shadow
Chief secretary to the treasury Pat
McFadden who joins us on the program as
McFadden good to see you this morning
I'm just wondering your reaction to well
in the next handful of ours at the fact
that we will now have a British Asian as
prime minister
well on a personal level uh I think
that's a big and historic milestone for
the country the population of the UK has
changed a lot over the years uh and you
know I you know I think it's important
to be generous at moments like this and
recognize these historic Milestones so
uh you know my differences with Richie
sunac will be about politics and policy
on a personal level I do think this is a
big important Milestone the fact that
we've got the first uh British Asian
prime minister
so so where do you see at the problems
with a Rishi sunai Premiership I mean
I'm presuming that the the labor party
has lived them since indeed the SNP are
doing are still calling for a general
election now
the problem is the conservative party uh
he's the third prime minister in three
months the fifth conservative prime
minister in just six years we've had
four chancellors in four months we'll
have another cabinet reshuffle today in
another round of uh ministerial chairs
being moved around and the reason you've
had so much instability and chaos is
because it is a divided and chaotic
party and for a time that just affected
our politics but it's now affecting
people in their pockets and it's
affecting our International standing
we've seen that in recent weeks with the
spike in mortgage rates the emergency
interventions from the bank of England
and the cost of this isn't over because
the new prime minister's First Act
alongside his Chancellor Jeremy Hunt who
I think you'll probably keep in post
will be to have a fiscal event as they
call a statement on Monday which will be
the third and five weeks and the main
purpose of that statement the way it's
being billed is to ask the British
people to pay the price for the terrible
mistakes made from the mini budget just
just weeks ago so the ongoing cost of
chaos and instability in the Tory party
is still going to be paid by the public
no matter how many times they change the
faces at the top
but you you'll have seen this at the
figures the same as me the markets have
stabilized and he hasn't even become
Prime Minister yet I'm just asking why
Rishi Suna should not be given and some
form of grace period you're a few months
at least to see if you can actually deal
with the problems and if you're talking
about a general election it'll be
another three months or the best part of
another two months at the very least
before there would be a labor
Administration in place so why not just
give him the opportunity now to try and
sort out the country
because I think the the longer this goes
on this uh Merry-Go-Round of changing
the Prime Minister changing the
chancellor every month and all these
changes the further you get away from uh
the election result in 2019 what is the
policy Now is it going to be the policy
of 2019 is it going to be that remember
I do remember Gordon Brown in 2017.
yeah I do remember Gordon Brown back in
2007 resisting calls to calls for an
election and you know the financial
situation wasn't brilliant back then
either
yeah look it does happen that prime
minister will change during the course
of a parliament but this is the third
time in three months we've not had a
situation like that before nor have we
had a situation where we've had four
chancellors in four months uh nor have
we had a situation where with such a
self-inflicted wound as that many budget
a few weeks ago so I think there are
arguments but look in the end the
Constitutional position about this is
that with a big Tory majority the only
way there'll be an election is if the
new prime minister agrees to one so much
as I'd like to see one he probably won't
have one and I think that's been the
indication over the last 24 hours
do you know what Miss McFadden I think
you might have a point on that one um I
do want to just conclude though with the
way that this battle between the
government benches and the opposition
benches will be fought as we move
forward we are everyone assumes about to
enter you know austerity 2.0 in
political terms Rishi sunak will be the
face alongside his Transit of course but
he will be the face of some pretty
significant cuts that are going to be
made do you think that someone who is
worth hundreds of millions of pounds can
adopt that role
I don't think his personal wealth has
got anything to do with it I don't
really like that kind of uh Politics as
long as the policies are fair and to to
pick up a new phrase austerity 2.0 why
is that no one was talking about public
expenditure Cuts before the mini budget
uh of September the 23rd and what's
going to happen now is that the British
people are going to be asked to pay the
price for the Tories political and
economic mistakes that's actually why we
should have an election that's why we
should have a change of government
because this party after 12 years in
power is now tired it's clapped out it's
divided it doesn't have a plan for the
future so we can have a new prime
minister today and a new cabinet today
but they do not have any new ideas as to
how to take the country forward
apparently found in great to have you on
the program this morning thanks for
being with us